[Music]
on this saturday night war over words
thousands protest quebec's controversial
french language bill every quebecer
should stand up and and speak out why
some fear it's an attack on english also
tonight parents struggling to feed their
children i'm on the floor crying like
looking at them telling them i'm so
sorry i can't provide for you what's
driving a critical shortage of baby
formula across america plus what the
nose knows after covid rising cases of
perosmia robbing people of their sense
of smell and six-figure scotch when it's
sold that's it we won't see another one
the rare whiskey for sale in calgary if
you can afford it
global national reporting tonight
sophie louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with breaking news out
of buffalo new york where a gunman
opened fire at a grocery store in a
predominantly black neighborhood 13
people have been shot leaving at least
10 dead this is the worst nightmare
that any community can face
and we are hurting
and we are seething
right now as a community
the depth of pain
that families are feeling
and that all of us are feeling right now
cannot even be
explained
the fbi and buffalo police have a
suspect in custody and say they're
investigating the shooting as both a
hate crime and racially motivated
violent extremism witnesses describe him
as a male in his late teens wearing full
camouflage a black helmet and carrying
what appeared to be a rifle
investigators say the suspect may have
been live streaming the shooting online
before he was arrested
back in this country quebec's new
legislation designed to bolster the
french language is inching closer to
becoming law the province says it's
necessary to protect a language it says
is under threat but english speakers and
indigenous groups say it's an attack on
their rights opponents took to the
streets of montreal today saying bill 96
goes too far and will restrict access to
education health care and justice for
non-french-speaking quebecers amendments
in recent weeks have softened some of
the bill's most extreme propositions but
as dan spector reports it hasn't been
enough to stop the growing opposition
a massive crowd taking over downtown
montreal thousands of people choosing to
spend a hot sunny saturday expressing
their anger over quebec's controversial
new language law this really is an issue
protecting anglophone right personally
i'm feeling a little threatened
surrounded by a sea of english in north
america quebec premier francois lego
believes french is in danger and bill 96
will protect it those opposed say such a
law will have consequences every
quebecer should stand up and and speak
out against these detrimental
infringements on our basic rights and
freedom the event began with a rally at
an english language college many
protesters upset bill 96 will force
students to take more courses in french
a lot of things that are available right
now that won't be available because of
that rule the ordinary indigenous
leaders also expressing concern the bill
will make it harder for their
communities our priority is the mohawk
language and we're already english
speaking people so while
bill 96 is imposing a third language
on our people and it's going to make a
whole lot more difficult but education
was not the only issue on the minds of
the demonstrators others here because
they fear bill 96 will mean limits on
health care services if your doctor
speaks english and is legally not
allowed to speak english to a patient
there is something wrong in that
situation there are also concerns about
reduced access to the legal system and
new powers for the province to make sure
businesses are operating in french the
language police show up with no warrant
no for to search and seize and they can
force me to give my password and give
them access to everything that's on my
cell phone
politicians from all levels of
government joined the rally anthony
house father led a delegation of liberal
mps denouncing the bill and its use of
the notwithstanding clause to override
the charter we do not believe there
should be laws that take away the
historical rights of english-speaking
quebecers as the demonstration reached
its final destination outside the
premier's montreal office a small group
of counter-demonstrators greeted it with
french music
i think the bills should go more far
some believe this was just the start of
a movement mobilizing against bill 96
but that likely won't stop it from being
passed quebec's majority government is
expected to vote it into law in the
coming weeks dan specter global news
montreal
abortion rights supporters flooded the
streets of several major u.s cities
today in protest over a looming supreme
court decision that could signal the end
of legalized abortion nationwide
[Music]
hundreds of thousands took to the
streets across the country in the first
weekend of protests that organizers have
dubbed a summer of rage demonstrators
held rallies in response to that leaked
draft opinion from the supreme court
earlier this month which indicates the
court's conservative majority could soon
overturn the landmark roe v wade
decision of 1973. the court's final
ruling which could give states the power
to ban abortion is expected in june
supply chain slowdowns and product
recalls are creating a crisis for
parents across the u.s as they struggle
to find formula to feed their babies the
white house is promising action and
parents say it can't come soon enough as
jennifer johnson reports doctors are
warning even a temporary shortage might
have long-term consequences
across america store shelves selling
infant formula are going bare and
parents are panicking they're searching
left and right
you know i've gone to pretty much every
store and every called every store to
search for it and we can't find it
anywhere about 45 percent of infant
formula in the u.s is out of stock after
a key producer abbott nutrition recalled
several brands and closed its michigan
plant two babies died after drinking its
formula that left millions of parents
frantically searching for something to
feed their babies
i'm on the floor crying like looking at
them telling them i'm so sorry i can't
provide for you the white house has
launched a new website to answer parents
questions on the shortage while
promising to import more products
president joe biden is also demanding
u.s manufacturers immediately increase
production we have to move with caution
as well as speed
because we got to make sure what we're
getting
is in fact
first-rate product doctors are warning
the shortage could have long-term health
effects on the infants poor growth and
poor development
the baby grows maximally the brain grows
maximally and in the first year of life
so deficits in the in nutrition will
significantly impact the baby the same
level of shortages hasn't been reported
in canada but parents in the u.s trying
to order formula from north of the
border and other countries are being hit
with two and three hundred dollar
shipping fees
jess butler whose son's medical
condition requires he drank formula even
flew from seattle to texas to buy some
from a woman she met online i spent two
days
talking to her and meeting
trying to meet at places and she never
she never showed and eventually just
blew me off congress is now demanding
the four leading formula manufacturers
explain what they're doing to fix the
crisis in the meantime breast milk banks
are begging for donors to provide milk
for the most desperate and fragile
infants
jennifer johnson global news washington
governments across canada are trying new
tactics to stifle the runaway cost of
housing home prices have grown by more
than 50 percent over the past two years
a phenomenon that's given rise to a
widespread housing crisis and although
there are signs the increases are
finally slowing the pressure on
governments to act is leading to some
regrettable decisions ross lord explains
on the premise that outsiders are
inflating real estate prices by
purchasing properties in nova scotia
the provincial pc government decided a
new property tax would help level the
playing field my intention all along the
intentions of our government all along
were to improve home affordability in
march the average price of a nova scotia
home was up 23 percent from 2021. houses
routinely sell for much more than the
asking price the new tax went into
effect on april 1st but it was no joke
it was meant to raise 65 million dollars
for the province
but instead of cash there was backlash
mostly from non-residents who call the
measure mean spirited i thought it was
fundamentally unfair joel blau has
family roots in nova scotia he's been
coming to this summer home since 1948
a tradition he cherishes i'm an american
i'm not a canadian i've but i've spent
now almost 75 years every summer in nova
scotia
and i think they thought that uh it was
you know kind of a
a relationship that could be monetized
less than a month after he announced the
tax premier tim houston has decided to
scrap it saying it could undermine nova
scotia's welcoming image i believe the
risk
of reputational damage to nova scotia
is becoming more and more real and it's
something i'm not willing to accept so
we'll find another way to to address the
housing issue the federal budget
contains measures that are also
receiving some lukewarm reviews the
stuff they've done is not too
significant like for example banning
foreign buyers for two years those are
all band-aids the budget also allotted
billions of dollars for construction
something analysts say could make a
bigger difference by creating more
supply to meet the growing demand for
housing recent hikes and interest rates
are beginning to curb runaway price
increases as nova scotia and other
provinces wrestle with how much
influence they should exert and the
right way to go about it
ross lord global news halifax
government officials are also working to
lower record high inflation across the
country the bank of canada has raised
its key interest rate and warns more
hikes will come as it signals a
commitment to bring inflation back down
to the 2 percent target but some
question whether that's the right move
with many canadians carrying high
amounts of household debt this week on
the west block eric sorensen speaks with
a former parliamentary budget officer to
get the ins and outs of the bank's role
in addressing inflation eric
sophie at the gas pump on grocery
shelves just about everywhere prices are
going up and fast government spending
through the pandemic bottlenecks in the
supply chain and then the war in ukraine
brought a spike in oil prices all a
perfect storm for inflation to soar
we're dealing with inflation rates much
higher than the gov the bank of canada's
targets
on the west block kevin page the former
parliamentary budget officer described
an inflation rate we haven't seen in 30
years for decades the bank of canada has
kept close to the 2 percent target for
inflation through the economic ups and
downs but this spring inflation climbed
to 6.7 percent and because of that paige
sees interest rates rising in the months
ahead we should expect increases in
policy rates
mortgage rates consumer lending rates of
at least one to two percentage points
over the next year year and a half
inflation has put the bank of canada in
the spotlight i will fire the governor
of the central bank to get inflation
under control pierre poliev a leading
candidate for the conservative
leadership has bluntly said he'll
replace tiff macklin with a new bank
governor but kevin page doesn't think
that that would make inflation go away
and he suggests maintaining the
independence of the bank is important it
would be quite a shock wave a global
financial shock way to have a government
literally remove a central banker who's
by by all
intents seems to be doing doing a fine
job but in doing a very difficult job
page doesn't expect the inflation rate
to start coming down yet the next
monthly inflation numbers will be out
later this week
sophie
thanks for that eric sorensen in ottawa
and you can watch eric's full interview
with former parliamentary budget officer
kevin page on tomorrow's west block
right here on global
a tour bus operator has been charged in
connection with a deadly crash in jasper
national park nearly two years ago in
july of 2020 an ice explorer vehicle
carrying 25 people rolled down an
embankment on the columbia ice field
three passengers were killed 14 others
suffered life-threatening injuries the
company operating the vehicle brewster
now faces eight charges under alberta's
occupational health and safety act they
include failing to control hazards not
checking safety equipment and failing to
maintain and mandate seat belts on board
an rcmp report into the accident is
still under review prosecutors will
determine if the evidence warrants any
criminal charges
coming up a dire warning about a growing
global food emergency as the war in
ukraine continues
and later a groundbreaking study into
sudden infant death syndrome the new
research that may partially solve the
mystery of sids
with the war in ukraine showing no sign
of slowing the g7 is warning of an
imminent global food shortage and energy
crisis canada's foreign minister melanie
jolie is in germany for the summit and
says canada is committed and ready to
send ships to european ports so
ukrainian grain can flow to those who
need it the most
we are an agricultural
power we have a lot of knowledge and
expertise in grain growing and grain
shipping and we will make sure to free
ukrainian wheat
the main point of discussion at the
meetings food shortages caused by
russian blockades on ukrainian grain
germany's foreign minister says up to 50
million people particularly in africa
and the middle east will die in the next
few months unless ukrainian grain can be
accessed the focus for foreign ministers
now turns to berlin where sweden and
finland are preparing to apply for nato
membership but today russian president
vladimir putin warned finland's
president that would be a mistake
after weeks of heavy bombardment russian
forces are finally withdrawing from
marquis ukraine's second largest city
ukrainian officials say they're entering
a new long-term phase of the war despite
russia pulling back from herkey both
sides are still locked in a grinding
battle for the country's industrial
heartland in the east where russian
forces are launching mortar artillery
and air strikes focusing on supply
routes around the donetsk region
two people have been arrested in
connection with a fire in delhi that
left 27 people dead police say the
owners of a company that manufactures
security cameras are in custody after
the fire reportedly started in their
office the city's fire chief says the
flames spread quickly to other areas
where plastic and a large amount of
cardboard was being stored the building
did not have any fire safety equipment
like extinguishers if found responsible
the pair could face life in prison
ahead rising cases of perasmia why the
postcovid condition is nothing to sniff
at
you're watching global national
researchers in australia believe they've
found the reason some babies die from
sudden infant death syndrome the study
by doctors at the children's hospital in
sydney found a lowered level of a
certain enzyme explains the malfunction
which causes some babies not to wake up
if they stop breathing in their sleep
for years it was suspected sids was
caused by a defect in that part of the
brain the doctor in charge of the study
says families who've suffered this
tragedy can now know for certain there
is nothing they could have done to
prevent the death
one of the common symptoms of covid19
earlier in the pandemic was a loss of
normal smell and taste but for one woman
in alberta the smell distortion showed
up months after she had the virus and
asu lingo reports her story is becoming
more common
grade three teacher christy chippenock
hasn't been able to eat lunch in the
staff room ever since her sense of smell
got messed up garlic and onions are
really bad so if i'm walking down the
hallway i'm like oh my gosh like it's
just so and i feel rude obviously doing
that but
there's nothing i had to buy a nose plug
it started in february a couple of
months after she had coveted 19. her
toothpaste suddenly tasted rancid and
her favorite drink coffee smelled like
gasoline sometimes she smells hair spray
or vomit all day there are very few
things she can eat
meat is a no-no meat smells and tastes
rotten completely the condition is
called perasmia and it's becoming more
common as covid infects more people the
nose is that is the port of entry so
this is why we had especially with the
original variant so many people that
complained about the sense of smell dr
johannes fresnelli specializes in smell
research his team followed hundreds of
health care workers infected at the
beginning of the pandemic who had any
smell issues after five months one-fifth
developed parasnia after a year that
number had grown to half so we have
these sniffing sticks he says smell
training can help some patients so we
actually think that the the exposure to
those odorants helps the effector
receptor neurons the neurons in the nose
regenerate from from
stem cells that we have there dr carl
philpott in the uk is also studying
porosmia his theory is covid affects the
receptors in the nose for example you
take the smell of a rose 13 different
molecules that could have make up that
smell and if you can only pick up six or
seven of them you're getting a different
signal so you're going to get in part
pieces of the jigsaw and it smells wrong
the smells were smelling like they are
not
like they are atrocious christie's
beloved coffee maker sits unused and her
diet consists mostly of avocados she
says her co-workers and students are
supportive but the condition can be
depressing it is
so isolating sue lingo global news
next liquid gold the rare scotch with a
six-figure price tag
it's often said that scotch is liquid
gold but the bottle in this next story
is worth a lot more than its weight in
gold gill tucker has more on a rare
whiskey that'll set you back six figures
this is rather precious and it's
irreplaceable kept safe in its own
little custom-made box
a sight to behold a bottle of scotch
that's pretty old it was uh distilled
february 3rd 1940 during world war ii
andrew ferguson showing it off in the
back room of his calgary liquor store
certainly something long time customer
rob rosenfeld checking it out of the the
250 odd decanters produced it's the last
one available when it's sold that's it
we won't see another one
yeah so that's what a 140 thousand
dollars buys you wow you heard right 140
000 and it's yours it'd be interesting
to have at home yeah
i think i would have to have some rather
long and potentially difficult
conversations with my spouse something
that it no doubt sparked some
interesting conversations in a lot of
homes if you had a spare hundred and
forty thousand dollars what would you
spend it on pay my debts buy a car i
would buy a house would you spend 140
000 on a bottle of whiskey
definitely not who's crazy enough to do
that a gentleman in texas
bought one at a bar and bought out the
entire bottle for himself and some
friends to drink in one night andrew had
two bottles when the shipment came in
from scotland two weeks ago he's already
sold one rare pieces like this the
closest similarity would be something
like collecting art or fine cars
high-end scotches are a big part of his
business so this one here is a 50 year
old glenn glaza it sells for 11 500 or
shell out that 140 000 for something
really rare this is one of the most
expensive whiskey's ever sold just the
thing for a special occasion do you wait
for your 80th birthday did you wait for
two people to turn 40 or some
combinations of there within or just a
tuesday night or just a tuesday night
exactly gil tucker global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm sophie louis
tonight's your canada is grand bend
ontario we love seeing your canada so
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching colleen christie
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]